the biden administration also faces
questions over troubling new images from
the southern border these are border
patrol agents on horseback rounding up
haitian migrants who are seeking asylum
in the u.s thousands of people are
camped near a bridge in del rio texas
close to the mexico border politicians
from both parties are slamming the
government response manuel bojorquez is
in del rio manuel good morning
good morning deportations are being sped
up with one to three flights a day
departing from the u.s to haiti and an
additional 600 federal agents have been
sent to this section of the border to
help but an incident involving border
patrol on horseback has the department
of homeland security investigating
it is tragic and it is heartbreaking
after seeing the camp where thousands of
mostly haitian migrants are waiting near
the u.s border secretary of homeland
security alejandro mallorcas issued this
stark warning if you come to the united
states illegally you will be returned
and in one case an agent on horseback
can be seen grabbing the shirt of a
migrant appearing to whip him as he
desperately tries to escape
but majorcas was also asked to respond
to images like these border patrol
agents on horseback seen trying to keep
migrants from crossing into the country
as one group tried to pass an agent said
this hey you use your women this is why
your country
in a statement a spokesperson for the
department of homeland security called
the footage extremely troubling and said
dhs is investigating the matter aquia
los estados unidos how how difficult was
that journey some of the migrants who do
qualify for asylum have been allowed in
like ralder valsan and why did you leave
for sales
[Music]
there's no security in haiti
looking for a better life
javier martinez jr is a lifelong
resident of del rio he says citizens in
his city fear possible shortages of
medical care we are a population of 35
000 or more now we're accommodating over
10 13 000 more
our our little hebs our little walmarts
are not uh you know at capacity for that
so our our shelves are being a little
empty now
martinez says the closure of the
international bridge connecting del rio
texas to cidada cunha mexico is having
an economic impact because workers from
mexico who are allowed to work here and
cross daily into the u.s are unable to
do so and some businesses are finding it
difficult to operate tony
manny thank you very much